this is this is Nietzsche's one of
Nietzsche's great statements of what is
great one must either be silent or speak
with greatness with greatness
that means cynically and with innocence
what I relate is the history of the next
two centuries I describe what is coming
what to no longer come differently the
advent of nihilism our whole European
culture is moving from some time now
with a tortured tension that is growing
from decade to decade as towards a
catastrophe restlessly violently
headlong like a river that wants to
reach the end that no longer reflects
that's afraid to reflect he that speaks
here has conversely done nothing so far
but to reflect as a philosopher and
solitary by instinct who has found his
advantage in standing aside outside why
has the event of nihilism become
necessary because the values we have had
hitherto thus draw their final
consequence because nihilism represents
the ultimate logical extension of our
great values and ideals because we must
experience nihilism be caught before we
can find out what value these values
really had so one of Nietzsche's claims
for example was that as Christianity in
Europe transformed itself into science
he felt that that one of the advantage
to the Catholic domination of Europe for
so many centuries was that the mind of
the Catholic adherents who took the
discipline seriously or the dogma
seriously learned to interpret all
events under the under the schema of a
single theory and he thought about that
as a form of discipline so you could
imagine imagine that if I if I want to
teach you how to theorize I might teach
you a theory and have you adopted and
Nietzsche's point would mean be that
well that means you know a theory but it
also means something else it also means
that now you know how to theorize and
the important consequence of learning a
theory may not be that
period maybe that you've learned to
theorise now Nietzsche also pointed out
that once you learn to theorize you can
separate yourself from the from the
theory that gave rise to that knowledge
and so you can start to theorize even
about the theory that you mastered and
he thought that's what happened to
Europe as a consequence of its
domination by Christianity especially
because of Christianity's essential
insistence on the utility of the truth
now he thought that was transformed
after Catholicism into scientific
investigation but that the spirit of
theorizing and truth remained intact and
then that the consequence of that was
that the European mind was disciplined
by a Dogma then it freed itself from the
dogma then it turned its power on the
dogma and noted that the dogma itself
seemed to be grounded in nothing that
you could get a grip on the way you
gripped things with an empirical mind
and so it fell apart you know and that's
not saying much more than science posed
a fatal challenge to religion but it's
saying it in a much more profound and
interesting way and it also explains why
he makes this claim that nihilism is the
logical conclusion of the great values
and ideals so he didn't think about
nihilism as a counter proposition say
too dogmatic Christianity he thought
about it as the the logical outcome of
that